j'ai un peut embarquer mes amis là
dedans je les remercie à cette occasion
mais c'est vraiment une aventure a
expérimenté il faut aller chercher au
fond de soi ces trois femmes son avocate
au barreau de fort de france
pas de robe pas d'audience sinon
apporter leur contribution à une
association
on va soutenir en courant une
association qui lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes culture
égalité cette association nous a été
suggérée par madame le bâtonnier
laurence unal ozier lafontaine qui nous
a dirigés vers elle et nous avons été
vraiment
séduite par la perspective de courir
pour cette association
huit à dix mille euros c'est la somme
obtenue par les équipes
l'appel aux sponsors wright est louable
le barreau de fort de france
le premier au départ l'ordre des avocats
a décidé de financer une équipe de
sportive en l'occurrence nous trois ils
adorent à céline et moi même et de
soutenir ce projet de manière à pouvoir
faire vivre une maxime mens sana in
corpore sano un esprit sain dans un
corps sain
75 équipes de 3 225 participantes des
femmes qui vont allier souffrance joie
et plaisir à travers plusieurs
disciplines et le kayak course à pied
vtt un événement de référence féminin en
europe 100 % nature et 100% solidaire
j'oppose reste bien concentré sur sa
mission
j'oppose parce qu'on s'oppose à la
maladie de notre amie audrey qui est
décédé donc c'est pour ça que le haut
est aussi mis en couleurs parce que du
coup elle se retrouve dans notre dans
notre logo et au moins les présente avec
nous pendant le raid
on a une petite histoire en commun on
s'est rencontrés grâce à la course à
pied et grâce à notre bonne étoile
audrey
qui était ma meilleure amie moi je suis
venu ici grâce à effectivement à ségo
qui a eu cette bonne idée
et puis pour passer un découvrir une
superbe épreuve avec les copines et on a
embarqué toutes nos familles dans le
projet le budget de la manifestation il
a à peu près d'un million d'euros mais
c'est vrai que ça ça demande beaucoup de
travail ça il ya quasiment une centaine
de personnes qui travaillent sur
l'opération et c'est plus d'une année de
travail
demain c'est dans le nord caraïbe que
sera donné le départ de cette 5e édition